Speaker 1: I want to do like just one bit
of follow up on this entire Jared schmuck.
Let's go Brandon thing that took place
because even the last bits of the story
that we're still standing are now falling apart.
So I. On the one hand, who cares about this guy,
but the fact that he is being made a hero much
like Kyle Rittenhouse is now being made a hero by
the right really tells us a lot about where the
right is now, given who they are lionizing and
also murdering. That's another aspect of this. So
here's the story. This guy, Jared Schneck over the
holiday weekend was able to get on the phone with
Joe and Jill Biden. And during that phone call,
he dropped in the phrase. Let's go, Brandon,
let's go. Brandon is a euphemism or a code for
Joe Biden. So he told the president to go
f himself. Here's a reminder of that clip.
Speaker 4: This is a to you. This is for the
kids. I hope you have a wonderful Christmas.
Yeah, I hope you guys have a wonderful
Christmas as well. And let's go, Brandon.
Speaker 5: Let's go, Brandon. All great.
Hey, by the way, where are you in Oregon?
Where is your home?
Speaker 1: I think we lost.
Yeah. OK. So after this took place, this
guy, Jared SMAC, started getting criticized
significantly by some, although people like Don
Jr. praised him. But there were people criticizing
Jared Schneck because it's quite disrespectful if
your view is respect the office of the President.
You don't call up the president and say if
you go f yourself the equivalent of that.
And Jared Schneck started to say that he's a
victim, everybody. He was just expressing his
First Amendment rights and people are curtailing
those by criticizing him. And it's like no
consequences to your speech are also
protected by the very same free speech,
right, that we all share. And he also said
something interesting, which is I'm not a Trumper.
I respect Joe Biden. I'm not a Trumper,
I just have concerns. Cut to yesterday,
when Jared Schmoke appeared with former Trump
adviser and Breitbart propagandist Steve
Bannon wearing a red MAGA hat, saying the election
was 100 percent stolen and he wants us to believe
he's not a Trumper, he's just the guy expressing
his concerns. It's just a pathetic joke. Take a
look at the video. Let's listen to the audio.
Speaker 4: I know it was said in a in a
joking manner, in a humorous manner, but
it's a very serious thing. And I mean,
it's it was one way for me to like, I got a
chance right now to voice my disapproval of
of this man and his administration. And what is
Speaker 5: it? What is that? What is that this?
You're John Q public. What is that? What is
Speaker 4: that disapproval? Can you
define that for us? Yeah. By the way,
Speaker 1: the idea that we would particularly
like, it's great to hear from just random people.
That's great. We want to know. We want to take the
pulse of what's going on and hear from people. But
Steve Bannon's interest in hearing from this guy
who we only know about because he told
the president to go f himself like,
who in particular cares what this guy has to say?
Speaker 4: Let's go, Brandon is and I've said it
in other articles. I am a Christian man.
It's for me. It's God. First and foremost,
I don't follow any one man blindly. Some of the
media is run with that and said, I don't support
Donald Trump. That's absolutely false, Donald.
Speaker 1: And remember,
he said, I'm not a Trumper
Speaker 4: up as my president,
and he should still be president right now.
Why the election was 100 percent stolen.
So I just want to make that clear. But
let's go, Brandon is more than just if Joe
Biden is, let's go. Brennan is encompasses
the the entirety of our frustration with
Joe Biden, the administration, the leftist
mob, the cancel culture, the mainstream media.
They're the ones who made this thing. And where if
Speaker 1: Joe Biden is about the cancel culture,
what is this guy talking about?
Speaker 4: Or as as conservatives were able to
find humor in this? But there's terrible things
going on. We've got the debacle in Afghanistan.
I mean, they're not even talking about it.
Speaker 1: It's a verbal inkblot of just unhinged,
disjointed talking points.
But he's not a Trumper. Oh,
and also he's wearing a red MAGA hat anymore.
Speaker 4: It's crazy to me how quickly they
forgot that story. And no one's talking about it.
They're still people trapped over there. We've got
the supply chain issues, we've got the inflation
rates. We've got terrible policies on abortion,
a very pro-life person and absolutely terrible.
Speaker 1: What's funny about just this? Like,
I mean this, it's hard to find a more ignorant
person who thinks they are really informed the
abortion line just to pick one thing, right? The
abortion line is particularly wacky because Joe
Biden's been president 11 months, almost almost
a year. Right? Well, actually 11 three weeks
short of a year, Joe Biden has been president.
There has been no loosening of abortion policy
since Joe Biden took over from Donald Trump. And
in fact, with the Texas abortion law, if anything,
it is harder today to get an abortion overall
in the United States than it was 11 months ago
when Joe Biden became president. So when you
actually look at what these folks are saying and
there's lots of people who don't even pay
attention to politics, they just don't care about
politics, you ask them, who's the vice president?
They might not even know like people who are just
completely tuned out. This guy is an example of
someone who believes they are knowledgeable about
what's going on and people like this vote. And he
has no idea whatsoever. And at the end of the day,
he basically told the president of the United
States you to his face, and now he's calling
himself the victim. So let's let's make this the
final point on the Jared Schmuck story. He's no
one any of us should care about in terms of his
opinion. And he, despite being a Christian and
being from the side that says, we've got to have
the right, you know, tone and respect for all of
these different institutions. He is now being
criticized because he told the president to go
f himself. That's that's the end of the story.
And we'll have these clips on her Instagram. If
you are listening today and want to watch them,
find us there at David Pakman show on Instagram.